battery
apparently if I want results in life I
have to start talking to boys yeah I
wake me up if you're here in the London
area I've noticed a lot of therapists
are like older single women and I'm kind
of like if you can't maintain a
relationship why would I take advice
from you
listen just lonely things over here okay
without her man okay people think I'm
encouraging cheating no like I think if
a woman cheats she's trying to leave you
if a man yes yes yes yes just like it's
like it's like a handshake
women act like this is the most
unforgivable thing that he is the
ultimate bad guy the ultimate demon if
he does this I'm sorry sometimes you
contributed to it and women take no
accountability for that and that he
wants to go to the bar with his buddies
because you make that [__] a hell hole
because you are so unpleasant to be
around
and then getting hard so if they do
what's hard it's valued if we do what's
easy it's not I am so enlightened by
Pearl teaching us how being a man will
magically eliminate all of the
consequences of cheating you know like
breaking your trust with your partner by
lying to them getting another woman
pregnant that you now have to support
humiliating your wife causing family
dysfunction and bringing home disease
but Manchester yes yes it's like a
handshake that is one hell of a
handshake Pearl and promoting
promiscuity is a great way to help
create the single moms that her podcast
actively speaks out against their
amazing strategy is they don't want to
pass on resources to another man's kid
like that's why that's why they're
repulsed by hoes that's why they're
they're repulsed by like other people's
children you're probably wondering by
now where is Pearl's ring well I'm here
to inform you that Pearl is single and
unmarried at 26 years old and the reason
I decided to go to therapy is because
um in the next like five to seven years
ideally you know some things are out of
your control but ideally I'd like to be
married
story time I see her talk about getting
into a relationship I just keep it just
lonely things
that's all I can think about according
to her is because she is too picky
you're single over a certain age you're
probably too picky and I say that it's
because she's too picky because she
claims that 28 years old is pretty old
to be getting married what do men value
threatening men value youth how are they
getting youth when the average age of
first marriage for women in the US is
28.6 years old and pearl doesn't have
much long-term experience in dating
either according to this interview on
Yahoo News and what Pearl says online
about her dating experiences on various
podcasts she's only had a couple of
boyfriends if you can do the math of her
being 23 in the Yahoo interview they
couldn't have been that long considering
she just turned 26 in the past couple of
months and that got me interested in
knowing who is Pearl picking considering
that anytime a guy does something wrong
no matter what it is she tells women to
simply just pick better okay so then you
pick guys that she I discovered that
last year Pearl tweeted about a breakup
she had so I decided to go ahead and
check the archives and it turns out that
Pearl actually got catfished by an obese
man with two children on tick tock
obese man with two kids
thank you
I'm sorry I think I'm starting to build
a crush on this monotonous girl
's ran on Tech
tile is constantly dunking on fat girls
why do I need to look at your roles and
then if you want to
go on some whale boom Another whale the
cherry on top is that Pearl has been
pretty adamant about men having children
being a deal breaker for her for me
personally I don't I'm not into the guys
with kids it's not my thing instead of
immediately breaking up with him for
hiding two whole children from her she
instead takes him in to live with her
and her family to mooch off of them
because you know he was homeless when I
first met him so I like moved him into
my parents house so he could get an ID
too yeah and so my parents put him like
on our lease oh so that was how like and
they like moved him in for like he lived
with us for like a month meanwhile pearl
is out here humble bragging about her
bagging a rich one on podcasts he was a
millionaire like it was just like he he
didn't know what to do with it how did
you have a millionaire he was on social
media and I saw he lived like kind of
close to me and so I made like videos
saying like oh we should like hang out
okay man
I told you we don't got much commentary
for this one this [__] wow bro
hey they're here they're going through
it oh my God
they are exposing [__] oh my dick
whoa
homeless millionaire like if you've
never seen those videos of girls like
shooting their shots at guys no publicly
I was on tick tocks and I did a video
saying you know when he's not doing this
like comedic bed he's actually kind of
kind of fine like I live in Chicago you
live in Chicago we should like hang out
I am pretty confident that Pearl is
referring to her ex Wanya in these
instances because Wanya is from Chicago
like the millionaire actually talks
about in the video there are multiple
articles saying that one yet was
homeless when he was around 22 years old
I do find it funny that Pearl dating one
yet or people know him as angry
reactions was framed as her bagging a
rich one meanwhile he actually moved on
to date a more attractive redhead and
she's still single and unmarried it
seems like her advice on lowering her
standards to get married isn't working
out so well for her Pearl has the
absolute audacity to tell women to pick
better when she literally got catfished
by some girl's obese baby daddy on Tech
talk match
whoo my girl's going in my crush is
building yeah he has a lot of followers
but he ended up having to mooch off of
her anyway so not only does she
regularly dunk on obese people even
taunting them in her Tick Tock bio
before she got banned but Pearl will
even put all the blame on women for
obesity in America just like half the
obese population in America being men
how can Pearl dunk on fat girls so often
considering that she has clearly
neglected her own self-care this video
of her is only from one month ago and it
might surprise you to learn that she's a
professional athlete
[Music]
is she being petty yes is she making
points yes
do I approve absolutely yeah no damn
just Porky things let's keep going and
despite lack of self-care she still
spout a lot of statistics about fat
women despite being corrected on this by
Destiny
there's a lot of fat people fat people
stay with fat people the women by and
large are fatter than men women and if
you go in the U.S the woman's always
fatter BMI so in the U.S the average BMI
for a man is 26.6 and the average BMI
four one is 26.5 oh I stand corrected
the eighth turn
but even after he corrected her she
continued to misrepresent the statistic
how can we say that as a whole in the
U.S and the West were good wives when 80
of us are overweight and that's the
number one thing that men value there's
a lot of room for improvement with
Western women seventy percent of us are
overweight the average man makes more
than the average woman but the average
woman is fatter than the average man
that's so this is this is actually a
really good one because it shows that
all these people who say the red pill is
the truth or whatever when they're given
the actual accurate information they'll
still go back to peddling a lot because
it benefits their grift even though this
is something that most people just skin
past what I think it really shows is
that she's a liar and she will
purposefully lie and she's caught in
real time lying because it benefits her
audience and she can sell her product I
it's actually the most Talent thing in
this whole interview in a random way or
this whole video because you see her
lying in real time she got the right
information went back to the false
information because it appeals to the
people she wants to sell things to Pearl
speaks on men valuing attractiveness
Purity and youth and says in order to
get a high value husband or husband at
all you should be those things men value
Purity and youth yeah Purity youth
Beauty Pearl fails to meet these
standards herself despite wanting to get
married so badly not only is she
accurate on the thing yeah and she's
thorough in her research but God damn my
girls are Savage I don't even care that
Pearl is unmarried I just hate the fact
that she can't see clowns other people
for not being and she can't even do her
own [__] diligence to do her own work
but it's a bit what you said earlier
like like you was talking about he was
talking about oh uh women are being
detestable because they always argue and
stuff like that and they nagging so
you're making that you said that's and
it is it is true that's her yeah she's
she's doing exactly that she's The
Parlor opposite of what she preaches
yeah apparently if I want results in
life I have to start talking to boys
yeah and wake me up if you're you're in
the London area in terms of Purity
Pearl's not a virgin Pearl actually
wanted to partake in hookup culture but
I swear to God like guys don't try to
sleep with me
like like I said I've been on a date and
I would I would have been dead and you
just never tried it I was like
they are flaming a [__]
they are flaming a [__] they're
killing her they're killing her her
especially we're just witnessing the
murder with popcorn in hand I ain't
snitching on no one
we all saw it we not seeing a word to
the cops we enjoying this one that's a
thought of me not saying sheets yeah I
say nothing we watching this one so
according to Pearl I guess we shouldn't
be taking her advice considering that
she can't attract men even for casual
encounters I've noticed a lot of
therapists are like older single women
and I'm kind of like if you can't
maintain a relationship why would I take
advice from you
oh
okay veggie okay venti okay everybody go
to go on do your thing flaming yes who's
that girl Brittany venti okay hey guys
if you guys are liking this video go to
her Channel give it a sub go like you
know what I mean uh damn she's somebody
who expresses conservative values in a
lot of things but she's really good
about what she does at least from what
I'm seeing in this video so I mean I'm
gonna give her I mean she did this much
research you gotta go show her some love
yo give her some of that answer
installers okay now she thinks what's
holding her back is the fact that she's
like six feet tall I would say if
there's one thing that's held me back in
dating it is the height but I think it's
because of her desperation and they can
sense it along with her low standards
she just doesn't give off any feminine
qualities like I don't know like I'm
just being honest with you
like forget how I feel about her
personally as a person I can separate
the two there I've hated personalized
online but like she fine as hell or I
could see
Pearl has zero sex appeal
this is what it is
that's why she went on a date with a
dude and he didn't even try anything is
because
that's how that's what it really comes
down to this ain't even hate or this is
just facts guys if I'm lying you guys
get in the comments hey don't be a hater
be honest don't say you would hit it
because you haven't masturbated in three
months like if you had some options in
life and I would never talk about
somebody like this openly but because
she talks about desirability and she
can't find like I'm gonna just tell you
why you can't it's because there's zero
sex of people
laughs
oh hi yeah
you know summer is coming out and things
are going to be pretty hot for your skin
and you don't want to use anything
that's going to be able to
you know ouch
that's going to be able to hurt your
skin you want something soft you know
what I mean
come here
that's why PA's Henley has the product
for you yeah you do not want to use some
abrasive stuff on your skin some of your
are degenerate soap from the dishwasher
the washing nooks and crannies come on
pass on baby
summer is coming if you don't know what
to do with your skin I would suggest you
to use the level one box yeah there's a
bunch of stuff a scrub to get in the
nooks and crannies to get all the little
residue out you know there's a daily
facial wash there's also an AM
moisturizer with SPF 15 no it's SPS 20
for the sun yeah use them promo th
Henley use that thing it's really great
it's for your skin and it's soft
and
since uh the wonderful weather is coming
you do want to be able to use that and I
have a wonderful skin yeah thank you for
that
if you click on the link below you will
not only save 30 off your first box but
you will also receive a gift and get
your skin ready for summer you know
yeah
well that started how about you
and you know if a guy has all the like
all the things that you look for he
might cheat yeah so how can I how can I
be that mad if he cheats when it's like
I picked him would you accept if he's
just stepping up but not getting anyone
pregnant are we married no you're in a
relationship I think if I'm being truly
honest with myself or the right guy I
probably would how many times I don't
know how many times she's basically
announcing to the world hey I'm Pearl
I'll tolerate cheating please marry me
that is facts like
yo you just look pathetic yo I would
tolerate cheating from the right man
it's like you want to tolerate somebody
like betraying your trust
let me be generous let me be good faith
here maybe what Pearl's saying is like I
would allow a dynamic in which my man
could step out and like I would be fine
with it okay that's how the same that's
not cheating when you say cheating that
means that he is betraying your trust
that means that you guys have come to an
agreement and this person's stepping
outside of that if you're saying you
want a one-sided open relationship just
say that stop saying cheating if that's
not what you mean but if you're saying
you would allow somebody to cheat on you
regularly you're a loser okay sorry you
want to get in that's how I would see
you I would never take someone like that
seriously you can't even assert your own
boundaries and keep something in terms
of sync to your relationship solid how
you can educate your kids in terms of
respecting themselves and respecting
their Dynamic how are you as a Christian
woman going to educate your children in
that life at the same time doing
something that's complete that's one of
the worst sins in Christianity sorry
that's not gonna work that's not gonna
work but anyways
if I'm being good faith that's what I
think she might have meant
I wouldn't say worse sin but whatever I
mean it's one of the only things for
which you can break your marriage but
it's not one of the worst sins
no no why not this is not if it's one of
the only things that you can do to break
your marriage how would you say it's not
the worst thing because you can you can
do a lot in the marriage yeah because it
didn't happen it's not since it's not an
asleep inherently within the marriage
there's other sins that exist right and
the worst sin I believe is killing
yourself yes that is one of the worst
okay you don't say adulteries in the top
five I wouldn't know okay but is
adultery I think murder is worse
the top five there's sevens [__] like
stop no no there's there's seven deadly
sins adultery is considered a great sin
it's a great sin but it's just seven
main sins there's seven this is what it
says in Genesis it says maintaining a
primary bond with one spouse is
essential failing to hold one spouses at
the most important human relationship is
the beginning of problems that's
according to Genesis but there's a new
testament and the Old Testament okay if
a man be found lying with a woman
married to a husband
then both of them shall die according to
Genesis that's in the old testamentus
I don't know bible stuff
Leviticus hey
little Leviticus
Genesis all the [__] they sound kind
of as the Old Testament if a man be
found lying with a woman married to Old
Testament [__] okay you know what my
Christians I said top five there are
seven deadly sins there's seven but this
war says beyond that I said is it one of
the most serious ones and you said no no
it's fine okay okay we have enough we
have enough seven hey root slime
rustling get these comments he's he's a
Christian YouTuber who'll be doing this
thing he's reading a comment sometimes
he's about to be honest he wanted to
interview you too though what he wants
to interview you
why yes very insightful stuff don't
worry it's not like he's gonna slap you
over the head with a Bible see if he
does well he's good he's cool he's not
bad especially considering she's on her
dad's time number one I'm sorry I'm not
a Brokey my dad yells at me for
accounting every month and I have to
like organize like business expenses
versus personal
um so my dad does yell at me when I pull
out cash but if you can't see what you
spend it on Pearl reminds me of Pearl
from SpongeBob asking her dad Mr Krabs
for money how much is out of this costed
me here's the receipt
[Music]
daughter because he wants her to be a
star and he's paying her way to do so
sorry sorry that was a crazy nervous you
know Mr Krabs daughter is
what she is what she's aware
okay bro let's keep watching I'm not
gonna do that you're a little YouTuber
is tough I'm really tired of being broke
Dad I can't mooch off of you forever
[Music]
[Applause]
give me a
cash sure that Pearl understands the
real world struggles of the average
person from her 10 bedroom mansion you
guys wanna you want the house tour
foreign
but clearly there is one thing that
money cannot buy
and that thing is taste this video is
from Pearl's Channel called wife School
in the first episode she and Ally known
as Real Fem Sapien on YouTube Meetup to
improve on Pearl's fashion along with a
male stylist who is supposed to be
helping Pearl attract the husband by
improving her outfits so let's take a
look at some of the outfits he puts her
in perfect for a night out on the town
this dress looks like a trash bag
[Laughter]
all right bro I just got
she said it and we all went true yeah
whoa okay all right all right go ahead
let's go you are a little Savage it's
unflattering on her because it's
showcasing her stomach which is not what
she should be highlighting not only that
but the black is washing her out making
her look very drained especially
considering the fact that she normally
doesn't wear makeup going without makeup
is a personal choice and it's fine but
if you're gonna do that you need to know
your color palette or you will look even
more tired and sickly when you wear the
wrong colors I'm going to go ahead and
explain a little bit of color theory to
you guys color season is a system that
utilizes color theory to categorize
where each person falls under in order
to easily find out what colors look good
on them it's based on how their Skin's
undertones interact with other colors
and that involves how light or dark
their skin is relative to the hair and
eye color if you have warm undertones in
your skin you'll look more yellow with
green veins in your wrist and if you're
cool toned you'll look more pinkish or
reddish with blue veins on your wrists
if you have a warm undertone you should
wear warm colors if you have cool
undertones cool tone colors will suit
you best you have to have a trained eye
to be able to see it in some cases but
Pearl is cool toned as you can see with
her pink flesh in her skin Pearl is
either a light summer because of her
cool tone coloration or she would be a
light spraying because it's right next
to Light summer in the color wheel it's
a little hard to tell on the internet
but I know for sure she's on that side
of the color wheel if you look at
someone and the first thing you see is
their outfit's color instead of their
own natural coloration and features then
you're wearing the wrong colors The
Stylist doesn't apply this knowledge or
even utilize basic color theory and
instead he takes her to a cheap fast
Fashion Store like Zara if he were
actually good at his job he would not be
making these mistakes if money were an
issue which clearly for Pearl it's not
they're a better budget friendly places
you could go to for higher quality
clothes for example go thrifting but
yeah clearly Pearl doesn't need to go
thrifting he could have just taken her
to a higher end mall or a department
store honestly he just does her dirty
the entire time that's super cool
okay I I should confess something to you
guys this stylist I know who he is I met
him while he was in London he's actually
a fan of ours I didn't I just recognized
him I think this is purple's full
sabotage and so yo listen Leighton if
you're watching this shout outs to you
that looks really nice what kind of
where would I go with this outfit I
think you know I think that could be an
afternoon I think that could be an
evening outfit I think you could go out
in shortage wearing that you've got a
Canary Wharf to one of the bars down
there meet some nice high value guy he
looks at her with a straight face
telling her she's going to meet a high
value guy in this outfit
you remember what we said women are way
more vicious with women
sorry that's just facts
oh it'll look nice going out for errands
and having a nice dinner he's just
talking out of his ass so why don't we
read this one time
oh Ricky's a high eight like I don't
know how a stylist can honestly rate
these outfits so high yeah
okay he must think that she's a dumpster
because he keeps putting her in trash
bags
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh you know what this one's actually not
bad
angle it
I'm sorry yeah this one's all right this
is actually like the only one better
this is the only one that's fine because
he's done it now like three or four
times in this video and he's not
highlighting any of the flattering parts
of her body which defeats the entire
purpose of having a stylist help you
there are several different body shapes
but for Pearl she holds most of her
weight proportionately in her arms and
in her stomach and that should have been
taken into consideration when he was
dressing her regardless if she loses
weight her proportions will stay the
same relative to her other body parts
you can bring balance back to the body
by drawing the attention to the most
attractive body parts and away from the
least attractive ones using Color
patterns texture but of course he would
know that if he actually knew what the
hell he was doing as a stylist is
honestly just so frustrating watching
him not look smacks her in this outfit
the skirt does not work Pearl could have
put on some jeans with a wider cut at
the bottom to balance her upper heavier
half or she could have put on a skirt
that was A-line high-waisted and above
the knee but in middle of the thigh not
too short would have done the trick to
bring attention to her legs and away
from her stomach in the back because
it's too big that is side to side that
is that's pretty cool
foreign
these [__] outfits are jarred
that is proper like New Year's Eve party
type yes
fitted yeah you see how he literally
highlights her stomach with bright green
Sparkles I I can't take this anymore and
then he has the audacity he must got it
from Pearl the audacity to suggest for
her to tailor a Zara dress that won't
survive one wash she's getting pearly
she's getting [__] Zara but you know
what she's not just being she's speaking
facts she knows what she's talking about
that's the thing she knows what she's
talking about so I I'll take it you
might not like the delivery but I mean
hey you got your pizza it's still a
pizza literally go watch a fashion
Channel go watch Ali art on YouTube and
then come back to us when you actually
know how to do your job and some just
her frumpy style that's preventing her
from looks maxing it's also her
presentation with her hair she's not
bothering to style it and many people
are even commenting about it under her
Tick Tock telling her to brush her hair
girl's hair just needs a haircut with
some texturing to give it volume so that
it's not so stuck and flat to her head
her hair is very manageable how is she
going to teach other women how to
attract a husband when she doesn't even
put the minimal effort in her own
appearance I've noticed a lot of
therapists are like older single women
and I'm kind of like if you can't
maintain a relationship why would I take
advice from you
thank you
for your Rex so if she wants to be taken
seriously she should care about her
overall presentation including her
fashion hairstyle her attitude and
bodily self-care this situation is so
deeply embarrassing and desperate she
has no business telling other women how
to attract a husband I wanted to give
Pearl credit for trying to improve on
her fashion but she makes it really hard
to do so when even months after this
video she continues to show up on camera
with her hair undone unbrushed stuck to
her head no volume that was not why she
looked like she balding enough yeah
because you could see her [__]
because it's just because it's greasy
it's just dirty her hair is so it clumps
up together and there's no volume okay
all right I think we watched enough of
this if you guys want to see the rest of
it there's plenty of portions that we
didn't watch in this because we want to
encourage you guys to go watch the full
video so go support her because she did
a great job if you guys like this video
leave a like and comment but definitely
go there I'll say this I don't want to
have to cover this girl again okay I
promise you guys would do one last video
and I thought this was a good one
because I think it's summarize a lot of
the issues that exist with this person
and I think it also showed in real time
how she lies on purpose because it suits
her agenda financially so like we said
before we think a lot of these people
are grifting we think a lot of these
people want to make money off the fact
that men are upset men have real
grievances men have real issues and
these people want to speak to these
people and they're hurt and their pain
to try to get their money that's what it
really comes down to that's why some of
these guys will donate to fresh and fit
and say foul things to the women who are
on the panel that's why women men will
donate to Pearl so she can say things to
people on the panel it's their chance to
get back on a lot of these people it's
not surprising no and pearls
she is what she is
um but yeah I don't want to beat a dead
horse I don't want to I want to kill her
off again so I don't know how much else
to say what do you want to say
that girl was speaking fast
so she was speaking facts facts backing
up it was probably like harsh delivery
yeah but backing up with a lot of facts
so there's nothing much to say about
that but you know what I mean like
she does things to benefit herself uh uh
and that's pretty much it she wants the
non-com woman she wants an uncle black
woman
and yeah this is good she said it it
came out of her mouth you know I mean
why should I take advice from you yeah
it came from it came out of her own
mouth yo I mean you got catfish that's
that's the first time that she was not
lying my girl yeah you was not lying
there why should I we why should people
take advice from you was it if that's
really your goal like listen if a
woman's 28 unmarried I don't care but if
you talk about how it's your goal you
shame other people for not being like
[__] imma laugh at you I'mma laugh at
you you out here telling everybody to
get in shape while you suffer the
twinkie down your throat uh I'ma laugh
at you too that's what you Advocate I
don't care yeah you could be in your
late 30s not married I wouldn't be like
oh lonely I don't give up but you care
so much but if you want to shame others
if you want to clown other people
calling them whales meaning your ass
look a little frumpy yeah you can get
that work make sure you can get it make
sure that and you deserve it too make
sure that your bedroom is clean people
are giving you the energy that you gave
others don't cry now it's funny how you
know you moved to the UK only to live in
a glass house and to the rocks
there you go should have stayed in that
manage and stupid anything else you want
to say all right let us know what you
guys think about just the only thing